gucken uns die frage von jochen walter
an der uns diese per video geschickt hat
berlin mit erstaunen ist etwas dass der
weitere umgang mit corona offensichtlich
kein bestandteil der bisherigen
sondierungsgespräche war zumindest nach
außen nichts und das macht mich ehrlich
gesagt gelinde gesagt er wisse daher
meine frage helena sie haben mit
freiheit auf den wahlplakaten geworben
sie und herr kubicki am suggeriert dass
es bei einer regierungsbeteiligung der
fdp ein schwenk in der kohlepolitik
geben wird hin zu einem freiheitlichen
selbst verantwortliche umgang mit kugel
19 halten sie ihr wort bekommen die
menschlichen grundrechte
zurückverfolgen sie jetzt in der korona
maßnahmen und wenn ja wann
der länder die antwort ist ja wir halten
an dem was wir vor der wahl gesagt haben
auch diesbezüglich fest die epidemische
lage nationaler tragweite die ja
sonderrechte für die regierung begründet
und viele maßnahmen diese epidemische
lage muss enden
und daran halten wir weiter fest können
sie singen gesundheitsminister karl
lauterbach vorstellen solche
entscheidungen trifft ja jeder der
koalitionspartner für sich selbst und
davor muss man respekt haben wir würden
uns ja auf der anderen seite auch nicht
von anderen
personalvorschläge unterbreiten
na ja ist schon klar aber wenn sie sich
so formulieren ist das ja möglich
zumindest das in ihrer ampelkoalition
mit ihnen neben ihnen am kabinettstisch
karl lauterbach als gesundheitsminister
sitzt diese fragen stellen
sie mir aber ich kann sie nicht
beantworten weil das ist sache jetzt in
diesem fall der sozialdemokratie wählen
sie dort nominiert falls sie dieses
ressort besetzt so umgekehrt würden wir
uns ja auch nicht dort ist unser
personal das ist wahnsinnig höflich von
ihnen nur es gab kein besseres corona
streitgespräch als das zwischen wolfgang
kubicki oder ihnen und karl lauterbach
und demnächst sitzen gemeinsam am
kabinettstisch schwer vorstellbar
über diese fragen entscheidet ja der
deutsche bundestag als gesetzgeber der
muss auch entscheiden über die
epidemische lage nationaler tragweite
also das was herr walter da glaube ich
der name eben gefragt hat und wir sind
uns da unserer fahrt antworten sehr
bewusst und halten an unseren positionen
auf fest herrschte einigkeit in der
ampel dass diese epidemische lage
verlängerte
haben sie darüber verlängert nie dass
die dass die epidemische lange nicht
noch einmal kommt nicht noch einmal
erneuert dazu kann ich jetzt öffentlich
noch nicht sagen weil sie zu weit
auseinanderliegen das ist ja schon
auffällig herr walter hat ja genau den
punkt getroffen es findet sich dazu
keinen ort an dem papier ja weil die
frage der verlängerung der epidemischen
lage nationaler tragweite die steht
bereits ende november an und zu dem
zeitpunkt ist gar nicht klar ob es eine
neue koalition bereits gibt aber der
deutsche bundestag wird dann entscheiden
in einer besonderen situation eine alte
große koalition gibt es de facto nicht
mehr auf der anderen seite noch eine
geschäftsführende bundesregierung ab dem
26 oktober auf der anderen seite gibt es
noch keine neue koalition und in dieser
speziellen situation
verfolgen wir das ziel die epidemische
lage nationaler tragweite zu beenden und
allenfalls kann es noch einige
technische übergangsbestimmung aber da
haben sie bisher niemanden auf der seite
außer der afg ganz ganz ganz aus das ist
ihre spekulation
[Musik]